norville have you seen sorry to bother
you no okay I was gonna make a use your
white voice joke but I already have a
white voice so it could be wider it
could be one what did I tell you before
we felt wow that's such a nice lapper
golly gee oh I tell you that's really
old
[Laughter]
hey reject nation I'm Greg Alba what's
your name good sir I am Norval - Floyd
the Chinese one up me on the deep voice
here huh I got a match you you know yeah
well thanks guys if you don't know
anything about Norval he was first our
patron then he left then he came back
and now he's at my apartment
that's the story a long time ago yeah
reaction to it he shot a whole feature
film it's called be on deceive you can
check out that trailer reaction and you
could check out Norville's channel and
JC productions
this guy's an aspiring filmmaker he's
got a lot of talent he is almost as
handsome as me you got some work to do
man you got some work to do okay
whatever that's what I did with my
friends I put them down to raise my ego
up hey this is your patron video request
the kid who would be king I don't
anything about it do you anything about
it no not at all maybe it's like another
young adult movie okay you like Hunger
Games Oh interesting something like that
maybe that's the feeling I get wow this
is as authentic as a video ever yeah
right into this
[Music]
Hey leave alone it's a tough world out
there and it's getting tougher all the
time okay and the world is not going to
change it's you that has to change what
[Music]
you have to see what I found something
written on the card put it in school
totally I mean it's the sort of father
what if it's the sword in the stone it's
the kid version King Arthur whoa until
the solar eclipse when Morgana will
enter the world of the living
and I suppose so that's ridiculous I'm
12
so long as possible one beautiful
succeed
an ingenious and yes in order to monitor
incognito you need to assemble a team
Knights gathered a round table so that
they were all equal look quick bonus
this is like the kind of film you and
right I'm getting a strong Harry Potter
five
[Applause]
that Patrick Stewart
don't freak out okay ladies the link
please return it Stella
I love that in movies and they were like
don't freak out and they do something L
freak them out maybe be specific look
there's gonna be a person's hand who
pops up from this bathtub hole in the
Excalibur sword don't freak out just say
don't freak out I got like the strongest
Harry Potter vibe from this trailer I'll
tell you what though or it looks better
than the Jude Law version of the King
Arthur movie we got earlier this year
Charlie Hunnam mmm-hmm mean King Arthur
yeah yeah yeah I feel like the King
Arthur story is kind of just dying downs
if anything this is an interesting way
to read it because nine times out of ten
when I see these trailers for these kind
of movies I'm usually kind of whatever
about it or I just flat-out don't like
it this actually looks very charming
it's very amusing to me I like to take
they're using on it from having like
schoolchildren with the whole King
Arthur storyline yeah modern-day and
everything yeah they have it like the
whole like that one scene one had like
all the kids as like knights and
everything this is the kind of film that
I feel like will probably get a really
good Rotten Tomatoes consensus get a
good audience score but ultimately might
flop at the box office I have I can see
that yeah like even though this trailer
is doing pretty well right now on the
Internet I also get the strong
impression that I'm not entirely sure if
this is the kind of movie a lot of
people will gravitate towards it's cool
to see a movie with a bunch of kids who
are ethnically diverse though you know
you kind of got this instead of Ned from
spider-man homecoming you got an Indian
friend
yeah with your white male lead it looks
funny and the visual effects - it's
another thing is a lot of times a visual
effects on these kind of films often
look like oh you need a more money you
needed a better budget but the visual
effects here when they're doing like the
crazy demonic creatures actually look
pretty neat to me my thing in CGI I'm
not one of those people be like Oh CGI
is bad or see guys isn't and that if
you're looking at the script to be like
okay we need like a fiery demon creature
the directors not gonna be like okay
well I don't want to use CGI let's get
an actual demon creature
yeah let's grab the Ouija board bring
them up we need you to act in this movie
you can't help but you CGI in some stuff
yeah I feel like this would be kind of
an inspiring tale I also like that
there's a king Arthur story but it's
about a little kid who you know we've
gotten to King Arthur movies in a row
that I've ultimately not performed so
well you got Anton fook-la one that had
Clive Owen as king Arthur which was like
a gritty version and then you had the
Charlie Hunnam one which was a gritty
version but then having this one right
here it's so unique but it has
everything yeah you got the round table
you can just having the Excalibur sword
inside of the stove the sword of the
stone and then for them to be aware of
this tale I like that element too I feel
like if it was the opposite where they
had no idea about King Arthur world are
you guys living did not know what's
going on before them til I pull out the
sword in the stone and go it's the sort
of the stone like there'll be references
will be a lot of self-awareness the
humor will really be a saving grace to
this film this could be a really
charming effective movie good but like
does have that young adult feel to it
Hunger Games or like darkest mind not as
dark like there's more Happy Tree but
like this market for this genre of kid
centric movies such as these yeah is
really tough because like you said
they'll have a good rating box off his
ankle to show darkest minds it didn't
have a good rating but the box office
wasn't good either
there's a reason why you know it's just
I know she's dynamic but hopefully my
hopes for this one yeah I would watch it
in theatres matinee movie yeah cuz some
of these jokes are fun and then some of
the jokes are like cliche I'm sick of
that joke of like someone who should
have know how to drive the driver how do
you learn to drive from Mario cursed and
steering but like the pedal and yeah
yeah the brakes in the parking what I
think would make this work is that
there's there seems to be a genuine
sense of authentic wonder about it you
know like they're little kids this is
like a kid's fantasy yeah because I I
watched this movie called the house with
a clock and its walls and
movie just wasn't for me and it felt
like they were trying to force this
sense of childhood wonder and there that
wasn't clicking with me and this is just
the trailer but even from just this
trailer I feel a natural sense of that
childhood wonder and that tone and
effect and go a long way and making a
movie effective and that's why I'm I
feel pretty sold on this movie you think
they'll make a franchise off if it does
I hope so the kid who could be king -
king again what is this heresy yes but
there's me John nor Val Karl - but
unless you ding that dong subscribe on
patreon and you can see people say
[Laughter]
anyway yeah that was a cool trailer what
do you guys think you guys can subscribe
to the reject nation hey click that
notification bell or ding that dong ding
check us out up patreon we got TV show
reactions in q and A's none of which nor
Bell personally watches I'm glad you're
here today for Val yeah NGC productions
be sure to watch the new trailers for
beyond deceived the new horror movie
they're doing inspired by Rick and Morty
do you have shirtless photos on your
Instagram I do have shirtless photos on
my Instagram yes I do so ladies if
you're interested do I follow you know
you don't actually then you should
follow me and I'll follow you right away
we'll follow each other yeah I don't
follow me about follow you oh okay I
don't think that's ok cool just gotta
make things weird